just happened he's always playing
forward
as they like to say
[Applause]
chris paul one on one with cousins
shot clock at seven paul a little shake
and bake drives past
him left-handed lay-up it's good
gorgeous move from paul
and then cousins knocks into paul are
they going to call a foul on that
[Applause]
[Music]
as we get under a minute remaining here
in the third the lead back up to 12.
the officials telling the players to get
away
[Applause]
others just shaking his head
let's take a closer look at it
well paul certainly looked to get some
contact cousins raised that right elbow
and paul sold it extremely well
what makes it tough is chris paul's
ability to sell it
marcus cousins allowed him to put it for
sale
sign up by using that elbow so you got
to be smart in these situations
and this is this could be a huge call
that's just a great move from paul tough
for cousins on that
oh my god come on man
so the officials right back at the
review table
but good response by phoenix yep they
went up by
17 but then a 10-0 run cut it to seven
and now phoenix has answered back
mistake out of a timeout in the zone
chris paul wide open three
if cousins doesn't throw that right
elbow and lets it go
well maybe he's trying to get it up over
him since he's walking right right
that's good to him as well that's a good
point
it doesn't look like contact but if i'm
either coach right now
with a little under a minute to go in
the third quarter of game six of the
nba conference finals let's let's cut
out the ant
tell the players knock it off don't let
that such a
hard-fought game here let's just go play
on is that what you're saying that's
what i'm saying because this would be a
one
two point ball game you got to be smart
and not surrender technical fouls
on free throw all right let's bring in
steve javi once again busy night for you
steve
it's a big call and and it's kind of
weird the way it happened tell me how
you saw it
it is i first of all saw a great acting
job by chris paul on flopping
secondly it's now the officials have to
determine whether cousins
throws the elbow or not if he throws the
elbow i would if i would if i deemed it
throwing the elbow i would call a
technical foul
not a flagrant foul in this situation
that's what they might go with the
technical foul but
chris paul really tries to sell it and
obviously he does
i understand what you guys are saying
too about cousins just trying to take
the ball and get the ball
to go out of bounds so this is a tough
decision but the most i would say would
be
a technical foul one shot thank you
steve jaby
one thing this doesn't if you're chris
paul if i'm the referee and i'll go over
there and take a look at that
i'm thinking you got me by overselling
it and it's going to be in my mind
refereeing you the rest of this ball
game i'd give double technicals
if you think if you want to knock it off
and you want to
let's hear from mark davis
upon review demarcus cousin will be
assessed the technical file for this
physical
taunt
all right steve javi gave us a thought
on that one so it's going to be a one
shot technical for chris paul
cousins meanwhile the personal foul is
first
chris paul to the free-throw line
excuse me nope no personal foul on
cousins
just just the technical foul
and chris potts only the second missed
free throw
of this series in the playoffs he was
46 46-50 from the free-throw line
in this series he was 15 of 16.